comment est ce que vous allez organiser
votre conciliation travail famille
chevrier hier avec vos enfants
on sait à quel point cette amitié
exigent la politique comment vous allez
là bas j'ai eu des exemples assez
extraordinaire dans mes propres par qui
mon père vivait évidemment c'est cet
équilibre famille travaille ma mère est
vide et déchire au niveau de la santé
mentale mais en même temps avec tous ces
défis qui vivait il était là pour nous
les enfants il avait une présence qui
m'a permis d'avoir quand même une vie
normale équilibré malgré tout ce qui
était anormale qui nous entoure est
sophie louet oui il faut délimiter faut
il faut savoir que quand ça avec les
enfants je mets de côté le téléphone je
mets de côté les dossiers et je suis
présent avec eux et pas en train penser
à ces vrais faux que je parle au premier
ministre de la france plus tard ce soir
qu'est ce que je pense pas à ça je pense
à mes enfants mais aussi dans l'
équilibre à quel point sont impliqués ou
visible dans les médias c'est un
équilibre à faire on veut qu'ils aient
eu une enfance la plus normale possible
tout en comprenant que ils ont la chance
et donc la responsabilité de vivre dans
un contexte particulier et ça vient avec
des hauts et des bas